lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es ir
explorando cómo modelar situaciones
usando ecuaciones diferenciales y en
este vídeo en particular vamos a ver un
modelo de una población entonces vamos a
ver un modelo de una población modelo de
población ok y veremos usando la lógica
de las ecuaciones diferenciales algunos
temas que seguramente ya has visto en
alguna clase de álgebra o de cálculo o
en algunos lugares también le llaman
clases de pre cálculo verdad entonces
para poder hacer todo esto vamos primero
a definir algunas variables así que
vamos a definir a la variable p como una
población aunque puede ser la densidad
poblacional o puede ser el número de
individuos el punto es que se refiere a
una población verdad y pues esta
población irá cambiando a lo largo del
tiempo entonces la variable t será el
tiempo y que por ejemplo podríamos
pensar que la variable t está dada en
días ok entonces no sé a lo mejor
podríamos pensar en alguna
y no sé por ejemplo de insectos que se
reproducen más o menos rápido entonces
la población cambia digamos tan rápido
como cambian los días a lo mejor
podríamos pensar en años por ejemplo los
seres humanos a lo mejor puede ser que
tengan una tasa de reproducción un
poquito más más más larga verdad
podríamos pensar a lo mejor no sé en
algún otro tipo de individuos que se
reproduzcan más más lento por ejemplo
del orden de meses verdad así que
realmente todo esto es razonable
mientras mientras estamos hablando por
ejemplo de insectos ahora cómo vamos a
modelar el cambio de la población bueno
podríamos pensar en la siguiente
ecuación vamos a pensar que la derivada
de p con respecto al tiempo con respecto
al tiempo es proporcional a la misma
perdón a la misma población es decir es
la población multiplicada por una
constante acá y esto es razonable verdad
mientras más población tengamos más
rápido crece la población verdad es la
probable
de que se reproduzcan a lo mejor es más
alta oa lo mejor pues tenemos muchos más
nacimientos por día mientras más más
individuos tengamos verdad entonces a
veces pensamos que las ecuaciones
diferenciales son cosas muy complicadas
y que se vuelven unos modelos sumamente
difíciles de entender pero realmente en
este tipo de ejemplos vamos a considerar
ideas muy sencillas y que son muy
fáciles de plasmar en en este tipo de
modelos en ecuaciones diferenciales
ahora bien ya que tenemos expresada
nuestra ecuación diferencial o cómo
cambia la población a lo largo del
tiempo lo que sigue es hallar la
solución general de esta ecuación
diferencial verdad y después podríamos
añadir algunas condiciones por ejemplo
condiciones iniciales para hallar
soluciones particulares así que te
invito a que hagas una pausa y trates de
pensar cómo podrías resolver esta
ecuación diferencial
ahora yo supongo que ya hiciste una
pausa vamos a vamos a trabajar esta
ecuación entonces lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es reconocer que esta es una
ecuación diferencial de variables
separables verdad y lo que uno hace con
las ecuaciones diferenciales separables
es pasar todo lo que dependa digamos de
la variable p de un lado y todo lo que
dependa de la variable t del otro lado
verdad y aquí por supuesto bueno lo que
lo que hemos estado trabajando es
digamos cómo despejar la diferencial de
t verdad o ir multiplicando estas
diferenciales
dt o de verdad y realmente esto es sólo
digamos
esto tiene una verdadera justificación
de por qué lo podemos hacer verdad digo
las diferenciales no son números uno
podría por ejemplo como pensarlo
rápidamente que en realidad esto es un
límite verdad de el cambio en p / el
cambio en t y eso sí son números y es
por eso que a lo mejor podríamos pensar
que se pueden despejar pero el argumento
principal se encuentra en el método de
variable de perdón de de sustitución en
las integrales pero bueno para fines de
este ejercicio sabemos que que podemos
hacerlo verdad entonces lo que podemos
hacer aquí es multiplicar por 1 entre p
de ambos lados 1 entre p de ambos lados
y luego lo que vamos a conseguir ahí del
lado derecho es que se cancelen las pes
y luego multiplicamos por dt de ambos
lados y nuevamente mencionó que esto
sólo es sabemos que se puede hacer
verdad aunque tiene una explicación
matemática formal muy bien entonces lo
que conseguimos del lado izquierdo es
que se cancelen las diferenciales dt y
dell
derechos se cancelan las p es verdad
entonces lo que obtenemos es la
siguiente ecuación digamos tenemos 1
sobre p por bp es igual a k por de t
por dt y ahora lo que podemos hacer es
integrar de ambos lados verdad aquí es
en donde digo que viene el argumento del
cambio de variable pero bueno vamos a
seguir la lógica digamos de estos
argumentos y del lado izquierdo lo que
tenemos es la integral de 1 entre p dp y
eso sabemos que es el logaritmo natural
del valor absoluto de p mientras que del
lado derecho tendríamos el aporte verdad
aporte y tenemos que agregar a que
agregar perdón una constante y voy a
llamar los eeuu no ahora porque eso lo
agregó la constante del lado derecho
bueno es que si tuviéramos una constante
del lado izquierdo que de hecho sale de
la integral de la primera integral
entonces la podemos pasar restando y
juntamos con la constante que sale de la
integral de la derecha y se queda como
solo una constante verdad entonces ya
hemos hecho esto varias veces así que
sólo vamos a dejarlo en esta constante
que es la diferencia de estas dos
constantes que salen a la hora de
integrar ahora bien si yo quiero
despejar la pues tenemos que sacar
una exponencial de ambos lados verdad la
función exponencial entonces nos queda
que el valor absoluto de p es igual a el
elevado a la cut
cada porte más
más de uno entonces podríamos seguir
utilizando el álgebra verdad porque
sabemos que el exponencial de una suma
es el producto de las exponenciales
entonces tenemos el elevado a la carte
verdad que multiplica a el elevado a la
c1
entonces lo que podemos ver es que
tenemos un exponencial de una constante
todo esto lo podemos llamar simplemente
una constante c mayúscula y entonces
tenemos c por el elevado a la corte
elevado a la k porte y aquí ya está
nuestra solución general de la ecuación
diferencial ahora bien nos faltaría
poder decir si quitamos el valor
absoluto de peón o el argumento es el
siguiente p es una población verdad
entonces no podemos tener valores
negativos de hecho si nosotros ponemos
de igual a cero de igual a cero
corresponde a una población inicial
verdad aquí nos da 1 y entonces se sería
nuestra población inicial que siempre es
positivo por eso es que podemos quitar
el valor absoluto entonces concluimos
que p dt es igual a una constante
y que multiplica y ha elevado a la que
aporte
a la k por t muy bien entonces ya ya ya
hemos visto este tipo de modelos en
álgebra verdad en álgebra se supone que
se modelan algunas cosas que crecen de
esta con esta fórmula cuando uno ve el
tema de exponenciales o logaritmos y
esto es bastante interesante porque a lo
mejor uno se preguntaría bueno y de
dónde salen esas fórmulas huesos modelos
y ahora sabemos de dónde viene todo
viene de una ecuación diferencial verdad
entonces podemos suponer que en esos
ejercicios de álgebra se digamos que la
regla viene de una ecuación diferencial
ahora en el siguiente vídeo vamos a ver
con un problema con condiciones
iniciales para poder hallar una solución
particular a esta ecuación